jackie good morning to you so we saw
uh the women there dancing outside
the uh hotel as they were celebrating
it's just quite a moment
for the team and of course for women's
football more broadly
i know and they've got some really good
dance moves having uh wrapped up that
euro victory uh they then danced their
way through the press conference as you
saw i mean how good at dancing is mary
epps the goalkeeper just fantastic and
she was really leading the celebrations
and why not she was pretty much woman of
the match because she
kept the the team in it with a string of
fantastic saves throughout that match
but i mean we've got to talk about the
winning goal scorer well both goals came
from the substitute so serena vegeman
has been quite amazing at subs
throughout this tournament you know
absolutely inspired and and chloe kelly
with that scramble's goal that made the
difference in extra time in the end in
what was quite a brutal match it was uh
the germans were very aggressive i think
um england knew that was coming but it
was quite a brutal match it wasn't super
high on quality at times i think there
was a lot of nerves out there initially
but england showed a lot of grit
particularly in that second period of
extra time when you could tell that both
sets um sets of players were extremely
tired and that iconic girl celebration
my goodness um i think she was in two
minds whether to take her shirt off
she's like shall i do it shall oh yeah
i'm doing it and it was brilliant just
waving the shirt above the head it's in
all the papers today it's all over
social media and that is her brandy
chastain moment brandy chastain the
american footballer who did that
celebration when she scored the winning
penalty in 1999 to win the world cup for
team usa and we're going to be talking
to her later on this morning hopefully
but you know incredible scenes at
wembley last night and serena vigmen in
her press conference saying we have
changed society
let's see now if this changes how women
women's football is treated and how
those players are paid